hey I'm Anthony Padilla I'm Ian Hecox
together we are Smosh and you're
watching the wired autocomplete
interview
[Music]
friendship always wins
hey where is the old slash oh we're
right here baby we're right here
oh my gosh oh my God where is the old
Smosh house
that is in Sacramento the address leaked
a lot of people started showing up to
our house and we were living there
people found it on Google Maps and then
labeled it as a place of worship it
doesn't anymore but I'm sure some of you
at home could could change that make it
a place of worship again why is Smosh
house floor
uh because we had many a stalker well
not not technically stalker there is you
remember the one time that we were
editing food battle and there were like
10 or 20 people like outside and around
and about the house and they were
bringing the doorbell ding dong ding
dong yeah yeah I remember you went
around the house while I was editing and
you were closing all the blinds oh yeah
I think a lot of the people that showed
up to our house were completely harmless
it was just like a lot of bored teens
and when you're like a teenager growing
up in Sacramento and you have a bike
it's like yeah why not just go try to
say hi to the Smosh boys yeah it was
probably harmless but yeah also a little
scary a little scary a little scary
little bit when was Smosh's first video
the first video that we uploaded to
YouTube was November 19th 2005 but we
didn't know YouTube existed yeah at all
it was just uploaded to smosh.com that
was the Power Rangers theme song music
video and somebody stole our video put
it on YouTube but that's how we found
out about it so thank you piracy when
was Smosh the most subscribed three
separate times
we're the most subscribed we got passed
up and then we took it back and then we
got passed up and then we took it back
and then PewDiePie passed us and then it
was just over from there
sorry I thought it was gonna be way
cooler okay you know it's gonna be a
good one oh no who is Ian heacocks
mom who is Ian heacock's mom little
backstory uh one of the most popular
recurring iconic iconic OG characters
from the old Smosh days was uh my mom
who was actually played by my mom she's
not an actor in fact she hates acting we
generally have my mom just say the worst
things to me call you a dumbass recently
she called you an amazing yeah and
it's just fun to make my mom curse Ian
he Cox
and Anthony Padilla still friends with
no question mark or anything I mean yeah
I mean that that was a legitimate
question for for many years we were
friends in the sixth grade and then
started this whole Smosh adventure
together we did that for about 12 years
and in that time of becoming friends
then becoming roommates but also being
business partners it kind of put a
strain on our on our friendship and for
a good while after Anthony left Smosh we
actually weren't friends we would
communicate but there was always
something that felt a little bit distant
right about it but like little Rockies a
little Ox we started reconnecting last
year yep hash it out learn how to
communicate like adults rather than 17
year olds It's pretty dope seems like
things are chill yeah adult friendships
are sweet friendship always wins
where is Ian he Cox from like Anthony
I'm from Sacramento California the 91
sickness
can Ian Hecox speak Spanish what do you
think that's something I mean people got
to know if if I'm bilingual you know
it's very very important it's because of
L Smosh the yeah yeah our Spanish
language uh dub Channel they want to
know if I'm the one doing the dubbing
the answer is no couldn't be me Ian
heacocks
Creator Clash no so Creator Clash is a
charity influencer boxing match they get
a bunch of creators and they have them
box like real hitting yeah they all
train for months they got ripped I've
attended the second one but you did not
fight you know I don't really like
getting head trauma for clout how about
this if this video gets nope 250 000
likes no Ian will fight I won't someone
Ian will okay I'll fight like a child
whoa okay oh okay was Anthony Padilla
emo
yes depending on what your definition of
emo is hair wise especially yes yeah
Aura energy wise yeah so much I was
heavily influenced by emo culture there
you go what do Anthony Padilla tattoos
mean I get that question a lot someone
yesterday I was at the airport this
really weird look on their face they're
like
doesn't mean something I I thought about
saying no but um honestly I know you're
looking for an answer but I feel like it
would take a very long time for me to
get into they mean a lot to me and
there's a lot of hidden messages in
there that are really just for me I feel
like I'm I'm kind of doing this thing
where I give messages to my future self
things that I never want to forget and
things that I hope to continue living
with for the rest of my life he hit a
live laugh love in there you'll never
find it does Anthony Padilla know what
corpse looks like yes corpse is a
faceless musician yes I do know what he
looks like I've interviewed him he would
not want me to say this but he looks
just as cool as people draw him that's
all I'll say oh that's all I'll say who
plays Anthony Padilla so there's this
Mario Lopez yeah there's this guy named
Mario Lopez and I hired to act out my
roles sometimes actually it's funny
because my mom used to always say that
she thought when I was younger that I
was going to grow up to look like Mario
Lopez I mean I see the resemblance
what's the famous thing he says
Saved by the Bell
let's see if I look like Saved by the
Bell whoa guys I think it's more foreign
all right
how to get on Smosh to be like Talent on
it I don't know be in LA and and be
funny and probably wait for one of the
other cast members to die of old age so
give it
I mean Shane's not long for this world
so probably like five years
Smosh beef and go we can't avoid talking
about beef and go beef and go is the
number one most viewed Smosh video of
all time which is crazy because it's a
the video is really mid it's Smosh
fanfic oh there's a lot out there I
think there would be less now about us
because we're we're not like
floppy-haired emo boys so like they
don't really want to see us make out as
much as they used to uh and we won't
talk about the milk fanfic anyway
brought it up again anyway I can't
mention them we don't mention the
infamous milk fan pick anymore Smosh
Legend of Zelda rap lyrics so we made a
Legend of Zelda rap spent a lot of time
writing that Ian played link you guys
elf ears and I played the the boss yeah
Ganondorf that was like our first like
big music video we had like a
professional cosplayer make us like the
costumes costumes we also paid someone
to make the the beat the instrumental
and then we went out to the mountains
like we like drove like two hours to go
film and it was a two-day yeah yeah
Smosh we summoned a demon so this is our
first sketch back and I'm so proud of it
it was the first video that we fully
wrote after deciding that we wanted to
buy Smosh back but we didn't know if our
our plan to buy Smosh back and start
making classic style sketches again was
gonna work I set a date I was like next
weekend you're coming back over to my
place and we're gonna write our first
sketch and we're gonna see if we if we
still click if we still have it yeah we
still got the juice
wow all right how did Anthony Padilla
and Ian heacocks meet ah so that was in
sixth grade we were doing a science
project I didn't have any friends so the
teacher kind of assigned us to work on
something together because I think
everyone else had picked someone we're
the losers funny how things just don't
change how old was Anthony Padilla when
he started Smosh Oh okay
I can't remember if I was 13 or 14 when
I made the first Smosh website but I do
know for a fact I was 14 years old when
I made the Smosh logo I remember looking
up what makes a good logo doing a little
fast forward sign uh picking my favorite
band Linkin Park finding their fonts and
putting a little s in between can you
can you like believe that we're still
using that that
ass logo for like this long we have
actually honestly tried to change it it
just doesn't hit like the OG nothing
it's like that logo how did Anthony
Padilla and Mikey meet
that's actually very funny my girlfriend
actually yeah and I officially met for
the first time on a Smosh collab we were
promoting Smosh the movie she and I did
not connect at all because I had many a
worry on my mind she actually thought I
didn't like her at all and then four
years later to the day we re-med up
again at VidCon of all places yeah I was
like what's up what's up girl
Smosh guy
perfect impression actually Anthony
Padilla daily dose of internet I just
interviewed daily dose of Internet many
people haven't seen his face I think
that's where most people are seeing what
daily dose of Internet looks like I
interviewed him on another Channel not
related to Smosh this is a show that I
started doing right after I left Smosh
the first time the first the only time
yeah you're right try to
force me out already I haven't been here
a month it's your first time so far yeah
what
Ian heacocks
little toe okay I was like Prince yeah
it's a video reference there's a video
where I play a Mumble rapper it was a
joke on Lil pump back when he was
popping off I thought it was literally
about your toe no I thought so too I
thought I thought it was about my toe
for a second I was like is there
something wrong with my toes we don't
talk about Ian's deformity I mean check
Wiki feet you can you'll know there Ian
heacock's old hair I used to have like
it wasn't an actual bowl cut no but that
was the best way to describe what it was
it looked more like a loaf of bread yeah
a lot of people call me like bread head
but people felt like a certain
attachment to the Bowl hair like do you
remember when you cut your hair yeah and
people are like he's not funny anymore
yeah no they cut his hair people used to
say that Smosh stopped being funny when
I cut my hair and a lot of people in our
new videos now are like it's not the
same without Ian's bowl or bread head
yeah yeah you know what that's fine Ian
Hecox Madame Tussaud we got uh wax
figures of the both of us it's like me
kind of like pushing you out of a stool
or something yeah we want it to be like
a scene yeah I think it kind of like
toured around some Madame tussos and
then it was like radio silence and we
don't we didn't know like where wax
figures went and then one day somebody
sends me a photo of my wax figure alone
with like a VR headset on my face
covering up as much of his face as
possible and like Anthony is nowhere to
be seen I'm just like
and it's so weird and that's the last
I've seen of it and I think we had to
start a campaign to get our wax figures
back they probably like melted it down
and then used that to build like Troye
sivan's wax figures probably yeah Ian
heacock's birth chart well I'm a
Sagittarius what's your moon landing I
don't know my Moonlight I don't
know
um yeah I don't know so I'm just a saggy
boom
who says shut up Smosh uh it's me so
shut up is like an intro card thing that
we do almost every single video starts
with some dumb sound bite and then it
just says shut up like the worst audio
quality you could ever have and it's so
funny because like people ask me to to
say it and it never sounds like bro it's
not gonna sound anything like it because
it's it was recorded on like a ten
dollar microphone 17 years ago
so that that sound clip will will
outlive me
who works at Smosh people yeah us it's
interesting to kind of go down you know
memory lane and think about how it was
literally just us in the beginning at my
mom's house just like messing around
making jokes for each other trying to
just make each other laugh and now
there's multiple sound stages and got
like 35 and full-time employees like
lots of really amazing people help make
Smosh happen and everyone is so funny
ooh there's multiple we did but there
was first alloy digital which became
defy then when that company collapsed in
2018 Rhett and Link's mythical
entertainment purchase they rescued it
and we say rescued because that could
have went a very different direction
many different companies were like
let me get that company let me buy Smosh
let me see what I can do so it
completely it was gonna be it was gonna
be ass straight up like if if mythical
didn't get it I wouldn't have stayed
around I was gonna say you didn't you
wouldn't have stayed right no no then we
bought it back
who is the smosh pit yeah the smosh pit
was the second Channel it was also a
website for a while so now the smosh pit
is this really fun unscripted channel
that we have that has our other cast
mates on it we do like uh kind of like
this improv show called try not to laugh
where you have a bunch of props and
wardrobe and you try to come out and
make the person in the stool laugh spit
out water it's all sorts of like fun
little unscripted shows who Smosh now
now for the main swash Channel we Smosh
now from the smosh pit Channel lots of
it's cool really funny people including
us and Smosh games lots of the same
people also They smash that playing
tabletop games board games we just
launched a D and D show so we're in that
d d game that's right critical role
we're coming for you we're not we're not
coming we're not really good we're not
you're doing fine you have your
territory we're just do our thing we
will not tread there we will not tread
look
all right we made it through the boards
yeah let us know what you thought Down
Below in the comments and we'll see you
on a different YouTube video
bye